von Miller joining us today on behalf of
new Old Spice foamer the foaming body
wash that lathers in a flash just like
Vaughn he's partnering with Old Spice
the foam zone obstacle course game and
you can see that on Old Spice YouTube
twitch and Facebook live today from 5:00
until 11 o'clock Eastern actually sent
us a goodie bag here and an autographed
picture of von miller von good morning
thanks for the goodie bag there guys
good morning how are you guys think I'm
doing pretty good take it one day at a
time
how does anything hurt today uh no I'm
feeling pretty good you know after a win
you know how little Nicks and bruises
they they don't feel as bad
did you watch Monday Night Football yes
sir what do you look oh I just at
anything I'm a fan of the game I just
like to watch you know great games and
uh Russell Wilson everybody knows about
Kaleo you know it was a great game
that's what I'm looking for do you
measure yourself against Colome AK I
feel like we're two totally different
players but when you look at it you know
whoa no probably like three or four down
there players in the league so at any
dating or all you know come comparison
all together so you know even you do you
don't you but um the fans are gonna do
it how surprised were you that Oakland
traded him I was I was super surprised
you know guys like you know and Donald
JJ Watt Kaleo Mac guys like that is just
untradable you know in my opinion you
know the Raiders did right ahead and do
this from it I'm sure the case Kingdom
appreciates the Raiders trading him as
well I noticed that you got eighty seven
and a half sacks in your career this is
your eighth season is there a Hall of
Fame number for sex do you know that if
you get to a certain number that that
means and because you're going to be a
Hall of Famer Super Bowl MVP but is
there a number for me I just like to go
out there and and play the best to my
ability and just you know add up these
years
you had of the years ago had the numbers
at end of the day you know they should
speak for themselves
but do you think the voters have a
number not you but do you think they if
you get to 120 Sachs oh my thing is I
think it's guys and I think if guys in
the Hall of Fame under 120 I think I
think the Marcus has the Marcus is for
sure going you know first-ballot
hall-of-famer he has you know 130 I
think he has 138 so yes I guess you know
right around there would the Marcus is
or no right around there but at the end
of the day I don't really have a number
I'm just trying to I was trying to be
the best you know football player I
could possibly be well you got four
sacks already the Clay Matthews hit on
Kirk Cousins did what did you see on
that play I don't think I don't think
you really tried to the only thing it
was really a roughing the passer you
know Carl but then again you know I'm a
I'm a past version as well so I felt
like you know everybody knows he's been
a huge um you know emphasis on you know
protecting the quarterback this year
after you know Anna Rodgers man you know
her hanging out for the rest of the
season last year so I mean everybody
knows that they're gonna try to protect
the quarterback but you know in that
particular moment I don't know I really
don't know though that was a tough one
on both sides of tell ya Vaughn you know
do you know how to do your job when it
comes to hitting the quarterback what
you can and can't do and now you know
you can't scoop the quarterback you
can't land on the quarterback I mean it
happens in split-second timing I don't
know how you guys do your job I mean for
me Oh what what helps me is I just go
for a ball I go for about every time and
I think if you really just focus in on
the on the football you're going for the
football every time then everything else
you know really takes you know care of
yourself if the guys throwing the ball
and I'm going for the ball and I'm like
slot for the ball and he throws it and
then you know I'm not really going you
want afford a quarterback that's I mean
it's supposed to be helping me you know
I have you know some of the biggest
retina pastor cars out though so you
know I have a couple reffering to pass
across but you know my my whole party is
just going for the ball and they're
usually nose yeah bit
you know I watch the Clay Matthews play
a couple of times here it wasn't violent
he put his hand down almost to kind of
brace his fall and and taking cousins to
the ground with him I I don't know I
just feel like there's no rule that has
benefited the defense in a long long
time and it feels like we're you know we
continue heading farther and farther
away from that you know what they you
know what they should do is they they
said calm or awful is opposing counsel
on the line that would be great do you
get held every play I mean I mean it's
holding on every single player is not a
game is it's play like it's holding when
you when you create separation the guys
still you know holding on till you go
you know they put a bigger emphasis on
you know common officers of holding on
the lineman then you know who knows we
have more follow we have we'll have more
rest in the past cause honestly how many
quarterbacks are bigger than you a lot
of me it's a lot um you know you look at
cam anything riders burger hams a big
yeah I'm like Georgia and 40 pounds 240
245 pounds so it's a lot of quarterbacks
right now I think Andrew Luck is right
around in there yeah so you got a yeah
it's a pretty big 40 bucks Jamie's
whiskers for you
he's von Miller the Broncos linebacker
and former Super Bowl MVP have you ever
heard a story like the Vontae Davis one
where he quitted halftime it's crazy
whenever you whenever you think about it
this is crazy man you know game day
especially first game day is the biggest
day of the week it's what everything is
about
and yeah I guess it halftime oh no I
really don't know it that's it so for
that's a tough I don't know if one of my
guys what if one of my guys walked down
on me you know you only have four year I
think it's worth it's 53 active guys and
you can only sue what 48 guys and you
have this guys doing doing special teams
and all this code to try to help you win
and then all of a sudden he's out not
because he's injured but because like
any wanna play them works
I guess that's I guess that's just a
tough one I wanted
how I feel about data for the Munchkin
ace kutami but wouldn't you say couldn't
you just you know stay on the sidelines
you you only have to be out there for
two more hours with us and you know that
all of a sudden at halftime you go you
know what now is a good time to retire
that's just strange it just shows you
man football is a tough sport physically
and mentally demanding sport and you
know you could you could break it you
know at any given moment you know I was
just mental that was a total but is
there stuff that still goes on in the
pile like when you say we know it's a
tough sport but what don't we see I feel
like I feel like the fantasy everything
so many camera angles is so many you got
something guys I'm you know my gonna
feel and then again there's so many
cameras I feel like the fans you know
see everything from the from the teams
you know Enzo and zona sound like
cameras to you know whatever network is
shooting but there's no punching or
grabbing or any of that stuff anymore
no I know that but there used to be days
when everyone please I'm so focused man
I don't you're on the you know be
technically sound and be you know and
get my assignment right for my teammates
I'm really focusing on that all the
extra stuff it is it's really you know
honestly I'm really not even thinking
about it
give me your a pitch for Old Spice here
or we say goodbye I'm no Spice guy again
which is uh which is being great too
and I'd be with these guys for so long
and you know we are promoting medium Oh
spices um summer it's interesting like
instantly lathering body wash and like
you said before they have the Old Spice
obstacle course and it's on Carlos bikes
media channels social media channels
from 5:00 p.m. to 11:00 p.m. and you can
check that out it's pretty clear they
actually have like a foam
statue of me that guys will be climbing
over so it's pretty cool I'm going to
give Fritzie the Old Spice bathroom yeah
cool yeah
give him the Oh spice bathroom plain
would be great but he wanted to be naked
underneath the bathrobe and I didn't
know if that was gonna be a good look
here Vaughn I mean is ready all right
Thank You Vaughn good luck with Old
Spice and certainly a great start to the
season thank you guys I appreciate you
guys having me again all right it's
meant to Mon Miller for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]